Good morning John, here in the
US the moment has arrived.
Everyone over the age of 16
can get the COVID vaccine.
Over 200 million doses have been
administered, and around 40%
of people have gotten at
least one dose.
And yet.
The graph of people
getting vaccinated everyday,
it’s starting to stop do this,
where it’s going higher every day,
it’s starting to go less and less
everyday.
And the reason for
this is largely younger people,
by which I mean people under
the age of 50 not getting their
vaccine immediately.
It could be
that you, watching this video
right now are one of those people,
or maybe you know one of those
people and you want to send them
this video.
So I’m going to go,
very quickly, through a few of the
reasons why I’ve heard young
people specifically say they haven’t
gotten vaccinated yet.
And first, I think tremendously under
examined, is just that like, it’s a slightly
unpleasant task that I
don’t want to add to my list of
things to do.
And since now you
can do it at any time, people
are putting it off.
Schedules are busy, and you know
that the day after your second
dose you might feel pretty crummy,
I certainly did.
So why not put it off
to a more convenient time?
But as with all procrastinations, look
there’s not really a better time than now.
But you also have to look
at what the trade off is, like we’re
dealing with mild inconvenience
that is scheduled versus unscheduled
major inconvenience and maybe worse.
The symptoms of COVID suck
no matter how old you are.
COVID does kill young people, it just
doesn’t kill very many of them.
The hospitalization rates are pretty high,
and spending a bunch of time
at the hospital is so bad.
It’s also like a burden on
healthcare workers who are
overburdened enough right now.
There are also a bunch of long
term side effects from getting COVID
that we don’t understand super well
right now, and those sometimes
also happen when people
get very mild cases.
But even if you get none of that,
it’s still really inconvenient to get
COVID. You feel like crap, you
have to quarantine.
It’s inconvenient
for you and everyone else
in your world.
So why not decrease the odds
of that happening by 95%?
But maybe you’re not worried
about yourself at all.
It’s still really
important to recognize that every
person except like the first
person who gets COVID, gets it
from somebody else.
And it’s very
easy to not know when you are the
person who got someone sick
because a lot of people get sick
by being exposed to people who
are infected but don’t even
know that they are.
If you’re
vaccinated, the odds of you
getting another person sick
go way, way, way down.
And then much more unlikely,
but even scarier.
Every one of the new
COVID variants that we’re talking
about right now, every one of them
evolved inside of a person.
And we will never know who that person was.
But I think we all can agree that
we don’t want to be that person.
Nobody wants to be the breeding ground
from which a new variant of COVID
emerges.
You can prevent yourself
from being that person by
getting a vaccine.
Now finally I’ve also heard some
people saying that, you know,
I got COVID, or I think I got COVID,
or I might as well just get COVID
and I can get immunity that way.
Leaving aside the fact that it is a big deal
and you might infect someone
for who it is an even bigger deal,
immunity from getting COVID is
much less effective at preventing
future COVID infections than the vaccines are.
So if you’ve
had COVID or you think you
might have, or if you think, I’ll just
get it and get immune that way,
none of that works.
You need a vaccine.
I understand that every person is
experiencing this differently, and
also that it’s frustrating.
And annoying.
Like this things has been in
charge of our lives for too long.
And for many people, a vaccine
feels like a way of taking back
control.
And for others, it feels
like more control that they’re
giving up.
For me, it felt like
taking back control.
And I think to some extent,
because the vaccines are a
really big deal, and they are
such a triumph of hard work
and human ingenuity, that it’s
easy to think, like, I have to
think really hard about this.
It’s something to worry about,
and to fret over.
But my friends,
it’s really not.
The decision here
is simple, it is both a big deal but
also not a big deal.
It’s just not a
big deal.
So if you need one final
reason to go get a vaccine,
hi I’m Hank Green.
I make science videos.
I’ve been making
educational videos for people for
free on the internet for over 10 years,
and maybe you want to do
me a favor!
It’s super easy,
there’s a link in the description
you can click on it, put in your
zip code, and make your appointment
for getting your COVID vaccine.
Put it in your phone,
then go do it.
And get a free donut.
John, I’ll see you
on Tuesday.